good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we almost never use the
term deep state on this show there's
something about it that sounds paranoid
even a little nutty as just a few years
ago you mostly heard the phrase from
relics on the far left the kind of
people who lecture you about the united
fruit company and the toppling of
mosaddegh
the term then and now suggests that our
democracy is fake elections and domestic
politics are just a sideshow no matter
who you vote for in the end the same
people still run everything that's a
pretty dark understanding of the
american system if you're a normal
person who grew up here it is the last
thing you want to believe about your own
country it seems crazy
and then you read stories like this one
according to reporting this summer in
the days after last november's election
mark milley the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff held a meeting with
senior military officials at the
pentagon mille wanted to inform them of
what he described as a serious threat to
national security a threat so grave that
it imperiled quote the stability of the
republic
that threat millie said was the sitting
president of the united states
donald trump had dared to question the
election results
for this milly explained the u.s
military might be required to use
physical force against the president
we're the guys with guns milly said
apparently he'd been preparing for this
moment millie had similar conversations
with the director of the cia gina haspel
as well as with the head of the nsa paul
nakasoni
he'd also spoken directly to chuck
schumer and nancy pelosi donald trump's
chief political rivals
now according to a new book by bob
woodward and bob costa milly apparently
went even further than that
on october 30th of last year woodward
and costa report millie called his
counterpart in china that's a general
called li zhou chang
mili did not tell his boss the president
about this call either before he made it
or after
here was millie's message for the
chinese military quote
generally i want to assure you that the
american government is stable and
everything is going to be okay we are
not going to attack or conduct any
kinetic operations against you
and then reportedly milly said this
quote general lee you and i have known
each other for five years
if we're going to attack i'm going to
call you ahead of time it's not going to
be a surprise
let that sink in quote if we're going to
attack
i'm going to call you ahead of time it's
not going to be a surprise
so according to this account our
country's top defense officials secretly
colluded with our chief military rival
to undercut the elected president of the
united states
how would you describe that
deep state is not strong enough that's
treason it is a crime
and apparently mark milley is not the
only person who was implicated in this
crime others knew it was happening as it
did
our intelligence agencies almost
certainly heard mark milley's call if
they can read emails from a cable news
show on fox what are the chances they
were aware that the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff was speaking to a
senior chinese general and what they
were saying well chancellor 100
and yet the nsa did nothing about it the
cia meanwhile was clearly fully on board
with this we are on the way to a
right-wing coup said gina haspel she
told millie that
and in fact there was a coup in progress
but it did not come from the right it
wasn't brewing in alabama
instead a constellation of unelected
government employees loyal above all to
the democratic party into the permanent
class in washington
ignored the united states constitution
and they invalidated the votes of tens
of millions of american citizens how'd
they do that because they invalidated
democracy democracy doesn't mean
anything if the people you elect have no
power
and mark milly did his best to make
certain the elected president had no
power
in early january woodward and costa
report millie called another meeting of
senior officials at the national
military command center
he informed this group that they
reported to him not to the elected
president of the united states and
that's not a small claim the national
military command center controls among
other things the nuclear weapons inside
our missile silos as well as the nuclear
weapons on board our submarines
so mark milley was seizing personal
control of america's nuclear arsenal he
went around the room and demanded that
his officers submit to his authority not
the president's milie told them to
follow no orders without first
consulting him
according to woodward and costa all
present in the room agreed to this
so civilian control of the military was
over mark milley was in charge
if this is true it is one of the
scariest things that has ever happened
in this country
you often people say they're worried
about authoritarianism coming to america
well it's here that's what this is it's
authoritarian government it's government
by unelected unaccountable leaders who
are willing to use violence to preserve
their power
that's what this book describes
it's shocking
not surprisingly our news media have
spent the day celebrating it it turns
out the self-described defenders of
democracy don't really believe in the
system they claim to revere the idea of
giving voters power over their own
government repulses people like this so
they're relieved to discover that in
fact our democracy is fake
here's a selection from some of today's
programming
i would call general mili a hero
he behaved in a heroic manner but what
he did was ensure the guard rails were
in place so i give him high marks for
this based on what's described in the
book i think millie felt ill used by the
episode in lafayette square when he was
used as a prop so one can understand
millie's anxieties we were in a period
of extraordinary danger i think general
milley is going to be treated very
favorably by history
so you heard forced people speak the
first guy you saw in that clip is rick
stengel and he's a [ __ ] obviously so
there's no surprise there the second guy
was some retired military official
but the last two
george will
barry mccaffrey
these are people who whatever you think
of them or who they vote for
you would have imagined might defend
american democracy when it came right
down to it
but no they didn't they cheered its
ending they're happy to see mark milley
secretly conspiring with the chinese
military to end civilian control of our
pentagon
so it turns out that's the government
they want
and you should not forget that
so now that we know all this what
happens next doug mcgregor is in some
ways at the center of this story he's
retired army colonel who last year
advised the trump administration on
foreign policy in that capacity he
co-authored a memo calling for american
troops to leave afghanistan finally
after 20 years
according to woodward and costa's
account that memo mcgregor's memo is one
of the reasons that mark milley decided
to organize a coup hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else